la communauté chilienne de france peut
voter à distance
ils sont déjà nombreux à s'être déplacés
ce matin au centre de vote du lycée
espagnol luis bunuel à neuilly sur seine
on va écouter quelques réactions de
votants ont recueilli par un nicolas
coupé sa maman très important pour
l'histoire du chili
on est derrière une constitution la base
d'une constitution qui date de 10 à peu
près une quarantaine d'années donc c'est
un moment très important de notre
histoire
moi j'ai bien d'autres savoir qui c'est
pas prévu si pas d'auto j'ai dit prends
le bus la genève
donc j'ai passé toute la nuit dans le
bus et moi je sais là et je pense que ça
ça valait coup on attend à renforcer les
pouvoirs des délais tard comme
institution est diminuée c'est comment
on sort des frondes que c'est 30 de
vivre fini dans lequel le pouvoir du
président on est est trop grand
extrêmement important que une
constitution pressoir valable pour tous
les chiliens
peu importe le niveau économique surtout
surtout pour les gens qui n'ont pas
accès à l'éducation à la santé